what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
wartime by frito bang before i start do
not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification
bell um while you're at it leave a
comment and let me know if you like
these
type of videos okay
[Music]
hesitate i was in that bottom just the
other day these [ __ ] rabbi kills i
know it did bring out the yellows
okay so he's just talking about how he
started from
like he didn't have a lot of money when
he was younger and now he kills it
okay so he's saying like other killers
give him respect
so essentially like they know that he'll
pull the trigger if he has to
know this [ __ ] i need him to get it
right cause you know my stick all up and
clench you can't explain in my
he's talking about how he likes dominoes
and
i don't know if he's talking about the
pizza or the game but
honestly they're both fun like i love
domino's pizza
i think that like domino's is a fun game
so
either way a good message
they shaking by their toes
oh no they didn't even cry about that
guy
at his funeral that's kind of sad i
don't like it when they go
like when people go after people that
are dead in their songs like let the
dead be dead you know
[Music]
i think he's talking about maybe a
nintendo switch um
which a nintendo switch can do a lot of
stuff um
i don't know what cause i don't play
video games but it does a lot
[Music]
[Music]
all right pick a dog that means like
pick up your friend
he's a tissue i don't know what that
means
maybe they're like teepeeing somewhere
[Music]
let's go let's go
let's go one time one time
i like the camo okay i can't i can't
deny it guys i was bopping my head
um i mean you saw me i was you know
shimmying and whatnot
but you know i don't like it when they
disrespect the dead so that like takes
off a point
um but i also liked the camo in the song
so drum roll please
i'm going to give it
[Music]
a 3.5
out of you guys know i do scales of one
to five i think they're more accurate
yeah okay let me know in the comments if
you guys agree
or you disagree you know either or do
not forget
to subscribe and let me know what song i
should do next
i'm gonna talk to you guys next time